the biggest success you feel you've both
had so far and where were you in your
life when this happened would you say oh
well for me the the biggest success I've
ever had was meeting you know you know
how has the had made everything you know
everything that good has come in my life
has been thanks to that you know so I
dad since that's the high point you know
I mean I've been very very lucky because
I met Elaine when I was I think I just
turned 20 and so that was perfection
that was great because again when she
met me I was just a little college
student there was no telling if I would
accomplish anything and she had faith in
me you know so I I mean when I met her I
already know she was wonderful but you
know she was taking a big risk in me and
it worked out but but I've been very
lucky because you know think of all the
people who as kids they want to be
writers or directors or or producers
they watch TV shows they say god I'd
like to be part of that world I want to
be on the other side of the glass of the
TV screen and I got to do that I got to
be that I mean my heroes were Rod
Serling and Ray Bradbury because they
were doing TV and books and movies and I
got to do all of that and and so I'm
very very lucky but Elaine had faith in
me and so and I was it's funny because I
was I was gonna say I was uninformed you
know when she met me you know I I wasn't
able to do any of the things I can do
now you know I mean and and but she had
already directed off-broadway she'd
already been an actress she had
adventures and so I'd you know she'd
already I think for both of us our
biggest success is whatever we're
involved in at the moment
we're not most looking back and we're
sort of drunk drunk on the moment the
abyss isn't with a moment and in a way
it's kind of sad to say well that was
the big time no I think it's that it's
the it's the ongoing journey you know
you have to sort of the success is the
ongoing journey and you have to be a
little bit crazy you know with each new
thing and say this is going to be
amazing
and so I don't think it's like one thing
it's we don't rest on our laurels I mean
right now is the exciting time I mean to
have my own studio to walk into a
building filled with spaceship sets I
mean I mentioned that when I was 10 I
went to the Star Trek set and when I
step onto that stage with our with our
spaceships that's it's the exact
I'm feeling it's that same thrill I'm
ten years old again and and to be able
to create something's like every day is
like Christmas it's just basically my
god wonderful actors wonderful people to
work with and to be able to write and
direct and produce with Elaine is such a
thrill because she brings the meaning
she makes sure that what I'm doing is
meaningful is working and and when we're
done with this we'll go back with our
editor and we'll sit down with our
editor and continue working and that's
just thrilling and so so we're just very
lucky to be where we are in doing what
we do so what would you say to someone
that might be listening to this that
feels that maybe they hit their peak
however many years ago and they feel
that there's no there's no way up for
them for whatever reason yeah oh just
say oh I would say that that has nothing
to do with their craft I think that has
to do with feeling stuck in life and
take a walk around the block talk to
people volunteer that you know bring
yourself back to your work something has
happened there's been a disconnect and
then I doubt very much of it has to do
with their craft it has to do with
something they've lost something inside
which can easily be regained if you
don't tell yourself a story you know
it's the stories that destroy us and to
just say get really enthused about your
life and it's not in the past all those
years even though years of misery
there's you know we were talking to a
large group of writers in a seminar and
two writers in the far front corner this
large room
they raised their hand I said well were
from Denmark and we'd love to work here
but we don't really were very different
a different culture you know we really
feel we have nothing to say we feel like
such outsiders and I said well why don't
you just turn around and look at
everybody else in the audience and they
did and I said okay everybody else in
the audience who here feels like an
outsider and every hand in the room went
up and I said I think you've got
something to write about and what's
what's important a lot of people don't
realize that it's like I feel so alone
and just say well everyone tends to feel
secretly varial
and so you understand that even in your
loneliness you're not alone so have the
courage and share it and that makes you
and everybody else feel less so and so I
think those feelings to say I'm feeling
it but I know it's bogus and I will push
through and what I would also say in
that regard is every day that you wake
up is another beginning and the past in
a way is an illusion it's sort of like
it's gone you can't reclaim it so all
you can do is say what do I want to do
with this day what do I want to do this
moment and you can be an entirely reborn
person but look for people who are
positive look for people who have a good
life energy look for people who allow
you your dream and if if you don't find
them where you are
come here come to where here where your
dreams can be made possible and don't be
stopped you know but don't be stopped
and find the way to make it happen in
one of my scripts that I'm in the middle
of polishing it was there's a place of
second chances you know and and and
somebody says they don't believe that
there's a place where you can get second
chances and they say what because if
somebody found out that there's a place
of second chances then this place would
be flooded and the fellow he's talking
to he said
laughs and says no no you're thinking of
the town down the way of damn good
excuses yes and and I think that when
sometimes people feel defeated there
part of them is looking for the good
excuse and not really for the second
chance because that we can make
endlessly yeah but one thing I'll say
just in conclusion in that regard I
would urge anyone who has a dream to
pursue it and to not be deterred and to
take a take a chance
you know and to really go for it and one
day I came home and there was a message
on my answering machine and it was Ray
Bradbury and he'd come across something
I'd written and he loved it and he
invited me to his house and that was of
course a thrill of a lifetime and I went
to his house and we hit it off when we
became great friends and the thing that
amazed me about Ray was that I knew him
in his 80s and into his
he died at 91 and and through that whole
time I met him after he'd had a stroke
and he his schedule as a writer had been
to get up at 5 days a week right for 3
hours then have lunch take a nap do his
business his writing you know the
business of his career in the afternoon
and then evenings and weekends for his
family and he that did that for 70 years
and when I knew him he'd had stroke and
his mind was fine but he couldn't type
anymore
and he ends handwriting was even very
difficult so what he would do to
continue writing was he would wake up in
the morning
holding the words in his head he would
then call his daughter in Arizona and
dictate the words to her she would type
them and then fax them them to him and
he would make hand corrections on on the
typescript he in that he'd that that was
how he wrote and he was writing two new
books a year through his 80s into his
90s and he was made of iron and so and
so this is the kind of person that I
wanted to be my inspiration in my mentor
because I saw how determined he was
nothing was going to stop him and that
was wonderful to see and certainly
something I want to emulate so I would
urge everyone to take that to heart and
not be deterred
you